oh this was not classic
I'm Katie topless and I'm a tech
reporter for BuzzFeed news and for the
last six years myself and my colleagues
Ryan and Cates and I put together a list
of today we'll be looking at some of the
weirdest things from that list for the
very first time I would just want to say
before we look at anything I'm
absolutely terrified I'm so nervous
[Music]
long Furby I'm terrified of snakes and
this kind of looks like a snake for
every to me this is weird
Microsoft 99 computer would crash and
you'd get like a pop-up blocker and
you'd start moving it that's exactly
what it looks like so this is a Furby
but long Furby of course was the popular
toy in the 80s and 90s someone who goes
by simply a lo they crafted their own
version of it where it was just really
long which is horrifying
this pasta recipe let's just be positive
it could be a great traditional pasta
recipe it could all right y'all here we
go oh I do feel like whoever made this
is like a really drunk and/or high
college student yeah how high do you
have to be to think about that this is
someone who made pasta but with Powerade
instead of water so my coworker Kate she
made this list with me her big
prediction last year for what the themes
of gross
things would be for the Internet this
year she was really sure that disgusting
food items were gonna be a big trend for
2018 and she was spot on this crocheted
baby
oh that's terrifying
oh that's so creepy I don't want to look
at it again get the F away like this I
believe that somebody had found these
crochet instructions on a website that
was for crochet hobbyists and it had
also made its way onto tumblr it's meant
to be a cute little doll but it is
absolutely horrifying looking the
analysis of Luigi's flaccid penis wait
all right here we go I'm bad at math
this confuses me
there was a Mario or Luigi wee tennis
game that came out and one of the ads
for it showed Luigi you know sort of
holding up his racquet and someone
looked at his shorts and noticed there
seemed to be an outline of his genitals
and they they sort of extrapolated from
the rest of the image how big the penis
on Luigi would actually be which like
you shouldn't do that this recipe for
cold hotdog pie I told you with me it
was do you like it yeah oh no no that
was horrifying you know the smell would
be bad
stop talking to me if you follow
BuzzFeed you've probably seen a lot of
our wonderful food recipes from tasty
that sort of show you in fast motion how
to cook a great delicious dish this is a
very bad dish that you should not cook
ever it appears to be from account
that's called well don't instead of well
done and this appeared on the mean page
means that will make you instantly die
to this rendering of the green M&M first
of all classic oh this was not classic
no no oh oh I really dislike this
actually I'm looking at the green M&M
get in fellatio for whatever reason the
Internet has always lusted after the
green M&M inexplicably
not the other ramen am is with the green
M&M and this is a particularly graphic
image of the green M&M with a female
presenting genitalia this Facebook
marketplace listing okay I have no idea
what this could be me neither but its
Facebook so it's not good this is gonna
be some like nasty furniture let's see
gently squirted on couch oh my gosh okay
gently squirted on couch it is exactly
what it says it is this was a listing on
Facebook marketplace where someone was
trying to sell their couch and you know
it had a few stains on it and it was
listed as they gently squirted on couch
no thanks this lactating nail-art
lactating nail I'm Karen oh oh what the
internet is weird
and all right I don't even know what
number on but I am exhausted y'all ready
oh my god I would just like to say that
this would probably give me it looks
like a pimple but it's also a little
boob
we found this on the Instagram account
that had like really over-the-top
terrible nail art ideas I have no idea
why someone made this or what was going
through their mind but I hope that they
get the help that they need
Domino's new I'm super nude Sano's you
already know what you're going to get
with it it's him nude then I stood oh
that's a penis that's his penis talk
about big energy and it's purple Wow I
think we could probably skip this one
yeah I think the Avengers movie was huge
in 2018 and there was a strange allure
of Thanos and there was a lot of people
on the internet who were very sexually
attracted to Thanos and made a lot of
NSFW fan art about Thanos and this is
the picture of him where it just looks
like him but then with just like an
enormous penis tied pawed flashlight
flashlight it's like wait wait wait wait
jimsy y'all gotta stop oh how do you
look first why forbidden snack for your
forbidden fruit right exactly like if
you can't eat at IHOP why not / so
obviously in 2018 eating Tide Pods was a
huge meme and we found an image that is
it's a rendering it's not real of
someone who made a tight pod fleshlight
a fleshlight of course is a thing that
looks like a flashlight that you can
like have sex with but imagine if there
was a tie pot on it you know it's good
clean fun
[Music]